[Music]
breaking news tonight canada's governor
general
resigns i would describe it as
unprecedented
the allegations julie pyed created a
toxic workplace
who takes over the role now canada's
mission to track the more contagious
kobit 19 variants
it's a search and destroy as cases spike
in an ontario care home
the new u.s president pumps up america's
pandemic plan
we're in a national emergency it's time
we treat it like one plus
what the end of keystone xl means for
western canadian oil producers
and from infection to protection how
long immunity could last
for covid19 survivors
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news canada's
governor general has resigned
julie pyed a scientist and former
astronaut has been accused of creating a
toxic work environment for her staff
the allegations were so serious the
prime minister's office hired an
independent consulting firm
to review them its report has not been
made public but it is said to be
scathing the governor general is the
queen's representative in canada
and presides over the swearing-in of the
prime minister the chief justice of
canada and
cabinet ministers late today the prime
minister released a statement saying
every employee in the government of
canada has the right to work in a safe
and healthy environment
and we will always take this very
seriously
mercedes stevenson our ottawa bureau
chief is following this story mercedes
what are your sources telling you
donna sources say that what is in this
report was
so bad so scathing that there was no way
the governor general
could have stayed in her job and that
the prime minister
was not happy with what he read in this
report and already strained but
functional
relationship he made the decision those
sources say
that essentially payette had to be out
of the job and that left her with two
choices
she could either choose to resign of her
own compunction as she did
or face the unprecedented scenario of
the prime minister going to the queen
to have her fired julie payette put out
a statement on her resignation
this afternoon in which she said she was
sorry but it's not a particularly
apologetic tone
detentions have arisen at rideau hall
over the past few months
and for that i am sorry she says that we
all
experience things differently but we
should always strive to do better
and for the good of our country and our
democratic institutions
i have come to the conclusion that a new
governor general
should be appointed so she is stepping
down but
the tone of that stepping down still
very interesting
mercedes concerns about how pyet treated
staff aren't entirely new some were
raised in her last job with a canadian
olympic committee
are there questions about the vetting
process for those being considered for
the role
absolutely there's questions about that
because how was this not caught how was
it that reporters were able to dig this
up how is it
that i and others spoke with members of
her rcmp detail who talked about how
they were treated
why was it that they were not able to
ensure such a high profile position
had the right person one of the
criticisms is that the prime minister
got rid of a vetting committee prime
minister harper had used to establish
governor generals
i talked to an expert about whether or
not a committee like that should be
reinstated to choose the next one
i think in light of what we're seeing
now that justin
knows decision not to use that committee
not to use that process
and come up with what looked like a star
candidate
on his own um somehow that didn't didn't
work out so well
so perhaps he will accept that
evolved process for selection
so donna there will be questions about
why the prime minister didn't get this
right
and perhaps why he didn't act sooner
okay mercedes in ottawa thanks
payette's appointment was approved by
the queen in july 2017 she was installed
three months later
governors general usually serve a
five-year term the role is especially
important during a minority parliament
the governor general has the legal power
to appoint a government
and the power to dismiss it that power
though is limited by constitutional
conventions
the chief justice of the supreme court
richard wagner will
take on the governor general's duties
until a new person
is appointed now to vaccines and the
pandemic the major general in charge
of canada's vaccine rollout confirmed
today no doses of the pfizer biotech
vaccine will be delivered to canada next
week
pfizer has said the delay is necessary
because it's retooling its manufacturing
facility in belgium
so it can expand production there
ontario's premier doug ford says
he doesn't buy that how there's all
these other countries around the world
getting them
and canada isn't getting them i said
down in the u.s as well down in
kalamazoo i'll drive down there myself
and
we'll pick them up if we have to i'm
going to be on them like an 800 pound
gorilla until
till they come up and deliver vaccines
on top of the vaccine delay concerns are
growing about how
fast highly contagious variants of
covid19 are now spreading in canada
preliminary results reveal a variant has
reached a care home in barrie ontario
where at least 25 residents have died
as eric sorenson reports the variants
are so much more transmissible
and detecting them is more complex than
a simple covid19 test
six cases of a covet variant in this
barrie ontario long-term care home
is just the kind of spike in
transmission that health officials fear
is just the beginning they're waiting
for a second round of tests but the
outbreak is serious
because covid variants are proving to be
more contagious
the spread was so quick and so uh
serious that there was a concern there
that it might be a mute
mutation mutant spread and which it is
canada is ahead of most countries in the
search for the covid variant
the canadian covet 19 genomics network
is looking for the missing gene in
samples from different parts of the
country
so we are looking at different groups
also geographical regions where there is
a
significant a rapid spike or increasing
number of cases there's a search and
destroy we want to find these in our
communities and we want to stop those
transit
trends of transmission so it doesn't
spread in our community
there are signs that recent restrictions
in ontario to limit
contact with others is working one
positive trend the curve of daily cases
in ontario peaked at an average over 3
500
10 days ago and has now fallen to 2751
a more than 20 percent drop but other
forces
like the covid variant could reinflate
that curve
yes lockdown is slowing transmission
but where transmission is happening the
risk
that it can increase even faster is now
higher because of the presence of these
new hyper transmissible variants
regular kovid checks do not identify the
variant positive results require
added genomic testing to get a clearer
picture of how much mutated virus there
is
all of one day's positive tests in
ontario
have just been scanned they're roughly
in ontario 2600
positive cases public on health ontario
will be doing this
s gene dropout test for the uk variant
on all of them
and we will actually hopefully sequence
all of those american health officials
expect the covet variant will be the
dominant
virus in the u.s by march health
officials here
say it's a critical time for canadians
to continue to limit their social
contacts
to keep numbers down until enough
vaccines arrive
eric sorensen global news toronto
there's an outbreak of covid19 in one of
the largest canada post sorting
facilities in this country
canada post says 121 employees at its
mississauga facility have tested
positive for the virus since january
first
the company says public health officials
have indicated most of the cases came
from the broader community
since the start of the pandemic more
than one thousand canada post employees
have tested positive the new u.s
president went straight to work on its
first full day in office
and president joe biden is not sugar
coating how bad things are
he says the death toll from covid19 is
on track to reach
500 000 people by next month the virus
is spreading faster than ever in the u.s
the deaths of more than
4 300 people were reported just
yesterday
when biden was sworn in the u.s has
lacked a national strategy and today
biden said he intends to fix that
jackson proskow reports the first day of
the biden administration
will set the tone for the next 100 days
in the fight against the pandemic
our national strategy is comprehensive
it's based on science not politics
it's based on truth not denial and it's
detail
on this day the new president revealed
his plan for controlling the dire
situation he inherited
things are going to continue to get
worse before they get better
the virus is spreading rapidly 100 000
additional deaths are forecast in just
the next
four weeks we're in a national emergency
and it's time we treat it like one
biden is asking americans to wear masks
and mandating them where he can
he's also mandating negative covid tests
for inbound air travelers and wants to
work with canadian officials on new
public health protocols for land
crossings at the u.s canada border
what's jarringly different is that biden
is addressing the crisis in bleak but
frank terms
the death toll will likely top 500 000
next month the cases will continue to
mount
unlike former president trump we're
doing so well after the plague
it's going away it was very clear that
there were things that were said
that really was uncomfortable because
they were not based on scientific fact
yet as biden tries to focus on one
crisis he will likely be drawn into
another
what a difference a day makes democrats
still plan to proceed with the senate
impeachment trial of trump
hoping to disqualify him from holding
future public office
for inciting the violent storming of the
capitol building
you don't say to a president do whatever
you want in the last months of your
administration
you're going to get a jet get out of
jail card free
a far different priority than the one
coming from the new occupant of the
white house
but both matters could come to define
his early days
jackson prosko global news washington
the company building the keystone xl
pipeline is laying off 1 000 workers
president biden has made good on his
promise to rescind the permit for the
project
and prime minister justin trudeau is
expected to raise it with biden when the
two
talk tomorrow our chief political
correspondent david aiken joins me
david is there anything the prime
minister could say to get the president
to change his mind
well no not really this was a major
commitment of the biden campaign they
campaigned for months on this and
canceling keystone is a key symbol of
the bite administration's commitment
to fight climate change now alberta
premier jason kenney is pushing to have
trade sanctions slapped on the u.s
in retaliation but trade experts are
telling me that
not only would that likely be illegal
they're unlikely to work
i don't think the government of canada
is going to bring an action
at this stage in our relationship with
the new administration
against the united states i just don't
think it's on
david what happens next for oil
producers in alberta and saskatchewan
who want to produce more
oil and get it to international markets
well as it turns out exports of canadian
crude to the us
has actually been growing even without
keystone more efficient use of existing
pipeline infrastructure
we've seen more oil by rail but even
still
the business case for keystone has not
really existed
for years now well i think what keystone
was
was and i guess is targeted at would be
new projects new production
and so right now given the current
pricing environment
we don't have any new projects currently
under construction
and let's not forget that the trans
mountain pipeline which canada bought
is being expanded trans mountain is more
than enough extra capacity
for uh the oil we're going to want to
export now trudeau might want to
convince biden to commit to developing a
integrated north american plan that
would allow both countries
to exploit oil and gas resources and
commit to rapidly reducing greenhouse
gas emissions
that's a tough order and there's no
guarantee that if they did such a plan
that a keystone or a successor would
even be part of it
donna all right david aiken thanks
coming up the new philosophy of the joe
biden administration
president biden said in his inaugural
address yesterday he intends to rebuild
alliances with the rest of the world and
restore america's reputation as a beacon
of hope
today his administration thanked the
world health organization for leading
the global response to the pandemic
that came just hours after the u.s
rejoined the paris climate agreement
as mike armstrong explains biden is busy
undoing
what donald trump did
one thing the new american president has
going for him is
good will joe biden's return to the
international stage
a welcome change for many international
leaders
after four long years europe has a
friend in the white house
the trump administration pushed the
slogan america first but the effect was
basically
america alone some have called it the
withdrawal doctrine
under trump the u.s pulled out of
international trade agreements treaties
and organizations
often with strong rhetoric as it walked
out the door
the paris accord was not designed to
save the environment that was designed
to kill
the american economy biden has wasted no
time
re-engaging the us in some of what trump
pulled out of he rejoined the paris
accord on day one
leading to an apology on day two this is
climate envoy john kerry speaking to a
g20 forum he said
with pain and embarrassment for the last
four years
the leader of our country chose to
pull out of the agreement and frankly
engage in
reckless behavior the biden
administration made it official at the
world health organization thursday as
well dr anthony fauci now working for
the biden white house saying it won't
pull out of the who
as president trump had announced this is
a good day for who
and a good day for global health a lot
of what
trump did is reversible analyst michael
o'hanlon says
biden can undo most of the damage done
to u.s relationships including canada
the new president is a known commodity
and well liked by traditional allies
but will the us be trusted like before
if countries think agreements can just
be ripped up by each new administration
that part is probably going to take a
little time to repair
and especially when you have to worry
that trump or someone like him may come
back
now parts of biden's to-do list are
tougher than others like the iran
nuclear deal some things will be more
complicated than just saying
we're back in mike armstrong global news
washington
there were a few notable fashion moments
at yesterday's inauguration but it isn't
lady gaga getting all the attention
today
it's a 79 year old senator from vermont
bernie sanders seems to live by the rule
that you only need
one good coat his old standby along with
a pair of fluffy knitted mittens made of
wool from old sweaters
sparked a storm of social media memes
he's been pasted into all kinds of
scenes from star trek
to fine art even lounging around a bc
brew pub
there's a website where you can put them
anywhere in the world
when asked about all the attention
sanders said in vermont we're not so
concerned with good
fashion we want to keep warm
words to live by global national is back
in a minute
boeing's 737 max returned to canadian
skies today
the planes were grounded worldwide
almost two years ago
this westjet flight took off from
calgary this morning bound for vancouver
air canada will resume flights on its
737 max jets on february
1st transport canada cleared the boeing
plains after an extensive safety review
announcing mandatory upgrades of
software and advanced pilot training to
fix the issues that caused
the two fatal crashes in indonesia and
ethiopia
346 people were killed including 18
canadians
the big question though is will enough
people
get back on board redmond shannon
reports
boeing desperately needs its best seller
to thrive again
the plane maker airlines and agencies
like transport canada have been working
since 2019 to get the 737 max
back in the skies they have modified its
software and pilot training
key factors in the two fatal crashes
canada has even taken the unusual
measure of adding extra training
requirements and cockpit procedures for
the three canadian airlines that fly the
max
i'd get in this aircraft and fly any one
of them for the rest of my life
without any qualms at all about the
safety
i think you're going to have trouble
getting people on board the
737 max 7 or max 8
but not because there's anything wrong
with it it just it has a bad name
in the early 1960s the lockheed electro
was the victim of a bad name
following three crashes the public lost
confidence and airlines gave up on the
plane
a westjet passenger survey suggests
two-thirds of canadians want to avoid
flying in the max
at westjet we put safety above all
canadian airlines will tell passengers
if they are booking on a max
air canada and westjet are initially
offering free flight changes if
passengers feel uncomfortable
flying on the plane you have to get the
aircraft into the air
and flying um you know and and
and flying safely you know and that in
itself
is is ultimately what's going to to
build confidence here
boeing knew of some of the max's issues
before the crashes and didn't tell
airlines it has since paid out three
billion dollars in fines and
compensation
rebuilding its max brand may eat even
further into its sales revenue
if you have to take a short-term hit on
the prices paid
then that will be regained in the future
as people begin to fly on the more often
the max is already flying in the u.s and
latin america
it's cleared for takeoff in europe next
week redmond shannon global news
london
post infection immunity next researchers
find hope in the antibodies of covid
survivors
over the course of the pandemic more
than six hundred thousand canadians have
become infected with covid19
and recovered it is assumed they are
immune from getting infected again
but it is not clear for how long
researchers in toronto have been trying
to answer that critical question
and as jeff semple reports their
findings so far are providing
much needed good news over the past year
this has become hart jackson's routine
providing regular blood samples and
helping to answer a key question
in the fight against covid19 part of it
was
to know that we had the immune response
still the cancer researcher and his
family tested positive for covid19
back in march after recovering he
learned his hospital colleagues were
developing
an antibody test to determine if people
who'd previously been infected with
covid19
are now immune as soon as the the trial
started i was
signing up right away and hoping to get
involved and provide any samples that i
can
now 10 months since his infection
heart's covid19 antibodies
remain robust and researchers are
optimistic
the expectation is and of course they're
continuing their studies
that the the immunity will last for at
least a year
hopefully multiple years recent studies
suggest covid19 antibodies peak
after four weeks but remain relatively
stable for at least eight months
so it still declines a little bit but it
declines very very slowly
and even after antibodies drop they may
still provide some immunity
a study of the virus in monkeys found
that even relatively low
antibodies were sufficient for
protection the immune response is
durable
however a caveat there is that there's a
lot of variability in that immune
response from person to person
those who experience mild symptoms for
example may have
fewer antibodies and a small number have
already become
re-infected for that reason
immunologists say everyone should
receive the vaccine
even if they've had the virus now i
would suggest that those people maybe
not be at the front of the line but it
won't hurt to get the vaccine and i
think it's overall it's recommended
and vaccine immunity is also looking
promising
after four months antibodies from the
moderna vaccine were at similar levels
to those with natural immunity
providing covid19 researchers with a
much needed
shot in the arm jeff sample global news
toronto
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen we leave you
with a bit of a different your canada
tonight
ontario's premier trying his hand at
multiple languages to deliver
the same message stay home thanks for
watching
take care of yourselves stay at
home rest day ala maison daisai jolly
low fun hi okay
ecasa
iso